direkt hinter ihm vielleicht der grafik
ist wir sind mit dem wissen täter im
wesentlichen ja ja voll hätten von
hinten sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut sehr
gute assassine schlägt wieder zu
service es geht willkommen zu einer
neuen folge handicap teams wollte ich
bin mein handicap von saga dass ich
jetzt mal einwände und zwar hat er
gesagt wo gott hat emirat alles
weggenommen weiter schickt einem dass
die leute nur von hinten angreifen da
ist genau das das besagte handicap und
das fängt ja gesagt richtig cool hier
bleibt das ist eigentlich so ein
assassine handicap ich habe drei level
aber jetzt muss ich echt aufpassen dass
ich immer weg kommen die leute
ansprechen kann
stimmt ich darf dir nur von hinten
greifen die hosen an unseren schulen und
okay okay
drei levels zu haben macht so spaß zu
verzaubern
irgendwie war das erste mal an
direkt über uns
da ich sage das nicht verdient recht gut
aber ich würde jetzt nicht hingehen von
ihnen das auch immer von hinten auf
jeden fall hat mir keinen gegeben er hat
sich im netz moment irgendwie noch so
ein bisschen gedreht dass auf jeden fall
von hinten aus dass ihn das hat geklappt
es hat geklappt leute besser wäre
herausgestellt das war wirklich gestern
aber war es echt bisschen happy
nachspielen
weiter auf dem tisch der assassin ist
auf der jagd der fossile läuft über die
webseite 7 und designer nächsten opfer
die er von hinten eiskalt reichen kann
der liebe s p hat natürlich
openbroadcast der frühere ubs hat der
kleine mann cannabis ist meint es war
noch niemand das heißt wir werden
wahrscheinlich auch niemanden treffen
dem wir jetzt direkt von hinten treffen
ermitteln müssen dürfen
ja das an die ard an besser aufpassen
hier ist irgendwo ein ja ist ja da ist
einer seiner drei seiner los komm raus
ich würde sein
schoko irgendwas schukow
konzert zwischen die säule aus komm raus
kommen zugriff heute zugriff zugkraft
von hinten sehr gut von mir sehr gut
eingegriffen zack zack zack zack zack
zack er versucht seinem schicksal zu
entkommen versucht zu rennen und es lag
gerade ein kleines bisschen korrekter
platzieren aber da ist ja besser
weggeschafft stand und wir haben kompass
leute wir haben kompass mit der waffe
die ihm interessant dass wir uns nachher
denn ich hatte gar keine worte
wir haben einfach drei lämmer ich weiß
mit dem level machen soll ich habe eine
angel und meinem roten teufel tätige
nicht dreckiger aber schlechtes wetter
ja alter auf gold später kann man kassa
sachen deutlich was ihr bis musste
wahrscheinlich schon aber gold lässt
sich extrem gut verzaubern es ist ein
bisschen material abhängig welche
verzauberung und kriegt habe ich gelesen
in minecraft wiki da steht ja eigentlich
in der regel keinen unsinn kein hupen
genügend buch ganz ehrlich für diese
change hätte ich gerne mal so ein
bisschen hacks oder sich im stück das
ich geschick ist nicht rumlaufen kann
jetzt nicht um spenden dann wenn die
challenge deutlich leichter so ist die
wirklich schwierig wir haben gestern
aufnahme versucht gehabt da ging es
überhaupt nicht da ging's spielweise
schon zwei kids on stage company europe
wird so wenn du pakistan gesammelt ist
kann ich ohne verpackungs werden möchte
mich für diese ausgabe ist ein kleiner
nein kann ich sagen keiner aber hatte
rief eine ziemlich heftige kdk bekommen
hat 67 dann glaube ich 6 8 6
zack zack zack
wir wollen jetzt aber nicht zu hart
pushen den jungen er hört sich etwas
ganz gut da vorne ist name davon als
name server nicht sind halt davon dessen
name davon dass namen zweier teams die
mit oder warte warte erstmal das sehr
gut ich bin ja ich davon wissen rein vom
alter geht dazu tritt auf ja ohne jetzt
ihr thema ist doch so asozial
ganz ehrlich da kannst mit einer karte
sonst wohin gehen wenn du ihm wenn du im
dm teams mal lieber meine fresse finde
ich nicht gut von mir ganz ehrlich finde
ich nicht cool
weißt du das siehst gibt kein wasser ein
schlechtes s kit gibt einen dislike so
wir haben aber jetzt sieben minuten auf
sich danach einfach nochmal rolle und
zwar einfach mal direkt in die macht
kann sich super an schleifen mache
einfach noch ein kurzer zickzack zack
zack sekunde auf platz 83 im ranking hat
bald ich hab aber die richtig hart
gepusht überhaupt 38 jetzt auch schon
auf 325 ist bei der menge an kills 83
empfehlenswerter feld versucht habe ich
mich würde mal interessieren wie wenn
man so dies das leaderboard sie anschaut
wie der also der youtube account mit den
meisten pc also mit dem höchsten ranking
sind
ich glaube stürmer flüssen auch extrem
weit oben er sucht nicht den guten
deutschland ihre marken ranking auf dem
fall geht weiter die assassinen
challenge und los
für das ist hier aus du immer extrem
wichtig da sie mit hier gar nicht
schlecht weggekommen für interessieren
auf welchen platz komme selbst ist der
jetzt hat wahrscheinlich so gut wie gar
kein sp kann man machen kann man einfach
schon weiter wir machen das gleiche
vielleicht aber jetzt erst mal nicht
hier bieten sich natürlich die häuser
wirklich perfekt passiert vielleicht
kannst du dir konnten jedoch direkt
hinter ihnen vielleicht minute der
plattenkiste wir sind hier im
wesentlichen von hinten voll hätten sehr
gut sehr gut sehr gut sehr gute
assassine schlägt wieder zu das obwohl
uns gesehen hat wir standen eigentlich
hatten theoretisch hätte und sehen
können wir stand neben ihm da unten ist
der nächste crash in die augen wenn ich
job job hatten als bibel willst du
dieses muster das haben die
einsteckschilder gemacht mich kurz
liegen lasse hier reinkommt 2002
du kannst natürlich den leuten auch auf
distanzen erst mit
moment moment optimal die laziali 2002
das ist eine kritische verwenden und von
hin ja sehr gut sei das kloster ein
entscheidendes ist es meist aber
immerhin immerhin und wir im kompass
ihren kompass leute richtig richtig
gefährde aber egal es assassine oder wie
lautet 2 diaz war läuft die leute der
kodex assassin max schreibt jetzt den
kodex als es in die kommentare wenn ihr
kennt ich werde ihnen gleich
laut aussprechen der lautet wie folgt
ich nichts ist wahr alles ist erlaubt
schöne grüße an alle assassin's creed
zucker da draußen die tore und so habe
es früher immer extrem kreis gefeiert
immer noch etwas gesehen alles gesehen
und gesehen dass dachte magazin nicht
passieren darf nicht gesehen werden
aber in so ein tier ein und das liegt
er ahnt ist association gebäude und hat
sich versteckt die runde wächst extrem
runde weiter
das beweisen nicht mehr hier unten
wir müssen runter müssen ganze zeit
gestorben
wir haben sticks wie am stick safestick
europe alters direkt beim start
wir können schaffen wir keine leute
moment meint müssen jetzt hier kurz
verteidiger ins eingegriffen was wieviel
alter wie viel erlebt jetzt abgezogen
naja diese katzenart die leute da und
mit ihm scheint auf jeden fall gut
gefallen auch wenn wir dem des macbeth
metzelder weg gefällt worden und gerade
eben auch auf mysteriöse art und weise
gestorben sind
aber ich fand es echt cool muss ich
sagen und ich will sagen was ich
gefordert wieder den daumen nach oben da
lassen
in die kommentare schreiben welche
handicaps in den nächsten videos sehen
wollt ich bin momentan im urlaub
behindert und hat wahrscheinlich eine
gute zeit und sonst würde ich euch sagen
leute die auch im urlaub sind viel spaß
ja und die noch fahren in zukunft viel
freude da wünsche ich euch haut rein
macht scott 11